abone ol
o zaman
İyi seyirler
abone ol
iyi bak
ve arazi
abone ol
ve bu işteki söyledi
bu 36
abone ol abone ol
abone ol
ya ben bu tam böyle de yok Ay bu da çok
oldu onu hiç sevmedim
Teşekkür ederim
36 yıla yaklaşan
öğrencilerin de daha iyi gelen bir hayat
olmuş 36 yıl düşününce Bayağı uzun bir
zaman dilimi yiyeceksiniz nasıl geçti
Düşe Kalka her düşüşte üstümü
temizleyerek kaldığım yerden devam ettim
ama şöyle bir şey var Galiba birçok
meslek dalında olduğu gibi
akademisyenlikte de süreç zor ilerliyor
erkek meslektaşlarımızla aranızda her
zaman bir rekabet var çünkü
O biraz daha iyi olmanız sizden
bekleniyor neden nedir Yani biraz daha
iyi olmak biraz daha bilgili olmak biraz
daha ilgili olmak biraz daha cesaretli
olmak derken kadınlar bu süreçte daha
çok fazla çalışmak zorunda kalıyorlar
bilim kadınları Aslında dünya çapında
çığır açan çalışmalara imza atmış
olmalarına rağmen küresel anlamda
129 luk Bir rakamla temsil ediliyor
Nobel Tıp bilim ödülleri yüzde 3'ü
kadınlara verilmiş ve Avrupa bazlı
yapılan çalışmalarda yürütücü kalan
kadın oranı yüzde on bir gibi bir rakam
Türkiye baktığınız zaman Arya bazı
çalışmalarda 137
doğal fen bilimleri Mühendislik
alanlarında yüzde 35 sosyal ve beşeri
alanlarda ise ben size 43'lü kalanlarda
kadın akademisyenlerin görev aldığını
görüyoruz
doğrusu Şöyle bir düşündüm acaba dedim
akademide durum nasıldır akademide biraz
daha hani farkındalıklar var mıdır Evet
eşitlik
kavramında Bir tık daha diğer kurumlara
göre belki biraz daha iyiyiz ama rekabet
anlamında da Son sürat devam eden bir
mücadelemiz var bizim
geriye dönüp bir baktım akademisyen
sayısı kadın akademisyen sayısı ne
durumda diye mm yıllarda 26.000
seviyesinde olan akademisyen sayısı bu
zamana 2021 yıllarında 80 91 malına
gelmiş kadın akademisyen sayısı bunların
11'i Profesör 7000i kadın Doçent 18
1000'de kadın doktor öğretim üyesi
olarak akademik camiada görev alıyor şu
bu düşündüğünüzde diyebilirsiniz ileri
toplumlarda Evet cinsiyet ayrımı artık
tamamıyla bitmek üzere bu noktada genç
arkadaşlarım olduğu için salonda
söylemek istiyorum kadın akademisyen
olmak aslında o kadar da çok zor bir
kavram değil bu noktada ne yapılması
gerekiyor işte ki tane önemli unsur var
Bunlardan bir tanesi ben yaparım
diyebilmek ben yaparım talep etmek
güvenmek ve o güven duygusunu karşıya
net bir şekilde il etmemiz gerekiyor iki
temel unsur ise
Özellikle de Bilim insanlarının ve biz
bilim kadınlarının genç kızlarımızı
cesaretlendirme miz genç araştırmacıları
desteklememiz gerekiyor
Şöyle düşündüm bu bu açmaya hazırlarken
ilk aklıma benim Kim geliyor acaba kadın
araştırmacılardan diye ilk aklıma gelen
Merkür'ü
oldum pek aklıma gelen oldu Evet Ciddi
anlamda çalışmaları olan bir kadın ama
onun dışında bir ile rol model olmuş çok
fazla kadın var işte bu akşam ben
tanıştım Onlarla bu akşam Ben sizleri de
onlarla tanıştırmak istiyorum kadın
akademisyenlerle bunu bir tanesi
Katherine Johnson ve müthiş bir zeka On
yaşında başlayan Matematik tutkusu ana
alıp götürmüş önce basamaklar sonra
yıkadı bulaşıklar daha sonra gümüşleri
derken diyor ki hayatımda sayılabilecek
her şeyi Saydım diyen ve ulusal ödül
almış özgürlük madalyası almış bir
kadından ben size diyorum öyle bir kadın
kim
14 yaşında lise 18 yaşında üniversiteyi
bitirmiş ve 1954 yıllarda nasıl ve
najada ciddi anlamda çalışmalarda
bulunmuş ki neden önemli diyeceksiniz
Özellikle de biliyorsunuz NASA'nın
Merkür ve Apollo 11 gibi uzaya
gönderdiği mekikler de aslında Katherine
Johnson payı var
böyle bir kadın ki Amerikan uzaya ilk
insan göndermesi yine onun sayesinde
gerçekleşmiş ve bu noktadan hareketle
2015 yılında Barack Obama tarafından bir
sivile verilebilecek en prestijli ödül
olan özgürlük madalyasını almış olan
afro-amerikan bir kadın
diğer ise YouTube
PES 2015 yılında Nobel Tıp ödülü olan
bir Çinli pelinotu yani antemis ya Anna
bitkisini keşfediyor 1600 yıllarda
Aslında
biliniyor bu bitki araştırıyor iki tane
etken maddeyi görüyor Ve onu sıtma
malarya hastalığında kullanarak
milyonlarca insanın hayatını kurtarıyor
v2011 yılında yine Tıp Akademisi Tıp
camiasında ünlü olan bir lasker ödülü da
aynı zamanda 2015 yılında birim kemple
esato şu Muğla ile birlikte Nobel
fizyoloji ve Tıp Ödülü alan bir kadın
diğer isidora Tea crawfort hacı diyor ki
kimya ve christaller tarafından hayat
boyu hapsedildi Mimo tuz 5 yılını
insülin yapısını anlamak için harcamış
bir kadın Selam bugün hali hep
kullandığımız baktığımız zaman kan
değerleri denizde gördüğümüz değerlerini
asla tüm moleküler yapılarını teşrif
etmiş bir kadın ve kurabiye tarifesi
tarafından Florence Nightingale den
sonra Başarı Ödülü verilen ikinci Bilim
kadını
bizlerden bir isim Safiye Ali
bilim kadınların seçilme hakkı için çok
mücadele etmiş kadınlardan bir tanesi
ama aynı zamanda bizim ilk kadın Tıp
doktorumuz ilk yine aynı şekilde Tıp
eğitimi veren kadınımız Safiye Ali'nin
özellikle bir yaş ve sonrasında
[Müzik]
Mahmut Reis cam ama hayır Orada yanlış
olacak şimdi bu kelime besin
yetersizliği ile ilgili alanlarda
çalışıyor ve hilal-i ahmer'in altında
evet çocuklar için bir muayenehane
Kur'an bir kadın yani anne çocuk sağlığı
üzerine ve süt damlası bakımevleri
Kur'an bir kadın Diğeri ise gençlerden
birisi bana çok umut veriyor Naşide
Gözde Durmuş O da yine aynı şekilde
emaneti tarafından tıpta ve biyoloji
değil de önemli isimlerden birisi 35 yaş
altı yenilikçiler grubuna girmiş
kanserle ilgili çalışmalar yapıyor ama
hücrelerin manyetik özelliklerinden
yararlanarak diyor ben yatar cihazlarda
üretebilirim acaba kanserli hücreleri
tespit edebilirim diyor yine çok hoş bir
hanımefendi Şevki tekniği diye anılan
bir tekniği var ilk kadın profesörümüz
bizim
1945 yılında Ankara Tıp Fakültesi
açıldığı zaman ilk ders veren hocamız
yine aynı zamanda biz ve ilik Pato kadın
Patoloji uzmanımız
1954 yılında Türkiye'de Elektron
mikroskobu laboratuarını Kur'an bir
kadın Ben de yapmış olduğu çalışmalar
neticesinde
oradaki yapmış olduğu yöntemle Şevki
tekniği Şevki metoduyla anılıyor ama bir
daha da önemli bir görevi var bara
Atatürk'ün naaşı Etnografya Müzesi'nden
Anıtkabir'e
getirilirken tahhüt görevinde bulunarak
bu alanda da hizmet etmiş bir
hanımefendi Canan Dağdeviren gençlerden
aslında bir fizikçi malzeme bilimci ama
öyle bir şey yapmış ki 10 saniyede cilt
kanserini teşhis eden çift benzeri böyle
dövme benzeri bir yapı oluşturuyor yine
Medikal alandaki çalışmalarını
kullanarak yine aynı şekilde pisces
çalışan giyilebilir bir kart çipi icat
eden bu adamlardan bir tanesi yine for
basın 30 yaş altı genç Bilim
insanlarından ve Harvard Üniversitesi
genç akademileri bulunan ilk Türk'ü İlk
Türk ve ekibi ile yine O da diyor ki
organların hareketlerini gözlemleyerek
Acaba ben bu organların hareketlerini
elektrik enerjisine çeviren mikro
cihazlar üretebilirmiyim diye çalışan
bir genç kalıp sizi daha hoş bir
hanımefendi ile tanıştırmak istiyorum
Dilhan Eryurt bir astrofizikçi
yıldızların evreni üzerinde müthiş
çalışmaları olan bir kadın Dilhan Eryurt
öyleki güneşin gittikçe parlaklık ve ısı
kaybettiğini keşfediyor ilk
keşiflerinden bir tanesi ve bu keşfi
sayesinde Aslında yine apollo'nun
ve görevlerine de katkı sağlıyor
1969 yılında insanlığın ayağı ilk defa
ayak basmasını sağlayan kadınlardan bir
tanesi Dilhan Eryurt aynı zamanda
nasa'da görev yapan ilk Türk bilim
kadını ve aynı şekilde NASA'nın dünyada
az kişiye verdiği Apollo başarı ödülünün
sahibi
i Bu noktadan hareketle Ben Ahde vefaya
çok inanan bir kadınım ve ben bir
öncekilerin Aslında her zaman onurlandır
ılması gerektiğini düşünen bir kadınım
bizden öncekilerin sayesinde buralarda
olduğumu düşünen bir kadınım O nedenle
geç meslektaşlarıma başarılarından
dolayı teşekkür ediyorum ama eski
hocaları Allah bize bu yol açtıkları
için sonsuz teşekkürlerimi sunuyor Her
meslek her yer kadınla güzeldir diyorum
saygılarımı sunuyorum
şu mor